pour juger de l'évolution vue jouer ces
trente dernières années voici quelques
exemples empruntés un collectionneur ici
dans sa boutique on ne retrouve que les
jouets produits dans les années 50 un
voyage dans la mémoire et qui laisse des
traces
pour ce collectionneur qui recueille
réparé et vend ses objets il s'agit d'un
véritable culte de l'atoll du fer et de
la couleur passion de collection d'abord
au début une dizaine d'années et puis
j'aime bien réparé les dommages qu à ces
jeunes va les remettre en état
voilà dans ce style quoi donc là ce
qu'il me plaît pas forcément c'est froid
c'est un matériau qu'une ou deux ans car
rien ça laisse aller sur rien quoi
gardons le lui ai offert
il était mieux et où il est
attendons la volée
marché
je ne sais pas
changement de décor les jouets 86
connaîtront-ils la postérité comme leurs
glorieux aînés
difficile tout va plus vite d'une année
sur l'autre les jouets sont démodés et
délaissée hier les jeux vidéo
aujourd'hui les jeux éducatifs tiennent
la vedette
l'important c'est d'obtenir un écran de
publicité à la télévision
voilà la publicité régie son origine
monde des enfants les enfants étant les
prescripteurs haut niveau les parents et
finalement c'est bien la pub régime
effectivement un produit télé va faire
partir le produit maintenant ce que ça
va faire durer ce n'est pas certain
mes parents recherchent l'éducatif ça
correspond bien
60 70 % des gens qui veulent des
produits vraiment éducatifs pour enfants
un jeu mais en même temps vous
connaissance géologique le thé
pédagogique
finalement pour les marchands de jouets
quelques produits demeurent inamovible
les peluches les voitures télécommandées
les miniatures ou les éternels patins à
roulettes un petit peu rajeuni avec un
look eighties
mais cette année un produit fait fureur
il vient des foires et des marchés il
tient de la marionnette et de la peluche
alors pourquoi faire compliqué quand les
bonnes vieilles recettes ont toujours
autant de succès